let's hear from some of the great people
in our audience we do this on our Friday
show you can call in through the David
packman show Discord which by the way
you should join anyway at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's start today with Dan from
Maryland Dan from Maryland welcome to
the program what is on your mind today
I'd love to hear what uh what you've
you've been thinking about
okay
David can you hear me yes
all right so you probably heard about it
now that my mayor was arrested for child
pornography your mayor I don't even know
what city you live in
College Park Maryland oh no I did not
hear about the College Park Maryland
he was arrested about 50 counts of child
pornography wow and I am absolutely
disgusted and disappointed because you
know I volunteered for him I campaigned
I voted and you feel pretty gross you
know after this happens but um my my
comment is more of you know she is an
openly gay man and I feel like this is
kind of feeds A Narrative of you know
the pedophile you know homosexual that
preys on children and I feel like with
what's going on with the anti-trans and
the drag queen shows and the more of the
laws that are happening I just feel like
it's a
I don't know it's a Log on the Fire if
that makes sense I totally understand
what you're saying and of course I mean
as as we know
um overwhelmingly the people arrested
for child porn uh are heterosexual and I
don't know of anyone who is saying we
have a problem with with heterosexuals
as a result of that and and one of these
things is what people create a narrative
and then they look only for examples
that confirm it but this is the first
time hearing of that story it sounds
like like he's been charged but not
found guilty at this point in time
that's always important to keep in mind
when we talk about these things but you
are without a doubt right that it will
be uh a way to throw a Log on the Fire
and that's the last thing we need right
now
yeah because also 12 Mayors so far this
year have also been arrested for similar
um I guess actions um as well and it's
just I don't it's just disappointing
that you know you live in a city and
your mayor gets arrested and so yeah so
I just want to say that you know I don't
really have a question I just wanted to
put that out there but um I also want to
say that I've been a long time listener
and I'm glad that you are keep going
with the show and you do a great job
thank you very much Dan from Maryland
appreciate the call
you're welcome bye-bye all right there
it goes Dan let's go next to Kevin from
I hope I pronounced this correctly is it
Tukwila
it's so cool
okay what state is that in
um it is in uh Washington State it's
like a 10 miles south from Seattle all
right well welcome to the show what's on
your mind today
well
um it's been a while since we last start
and um I I will go to you for um
for some uh really important questions
if um if I don't know the answer to them
and and I have one in particular and I
have a follow-up okay uh so the question
that I have is do you feel that the um
Biden's um green energy plan through the
inflation reduction Act is
um is like selling the cart before the
horse in what sense
like for for instance
um there's there's the um the concern
then that the that these green energy
projects might not
um there's a pro there's a process that
makes it so these green energy projects
are not enough
um
giving and given the permitting at the
at the pace they should be giving giving
their current
um
a current system and that's what that's
why I'm in Center managed to introduce
permitting reform
um there's also the concern that perhaps
um like
um
there's a there's a there's a button
there's um probably none enough uh
people in back can uh assume that can
take on the initial jobs those green
energy oh I see what you're saying no
listen I'm not concerned by that because
sometimes in order to create so you've
got to generate
if if the government doesn't first fund
some of these things the businesses
aren't going to start hiring and
training the people to do the work
because in general businesses aren't
going to say hey the government might
pass this so let's like hire and train a
whole bunch of people so I don't see
that as a bottleneck I don't see it as a
problem it might serve as a temporary
bottleneck but I think the right way to
do it is the government says hey we're
investing in these industries go grow
hire train people and there will be a
lag time but that's okay
I see um
do you also feel that that there might
be
um
I don't know some
some additional
um ways to make the process a little bit
more and more more efficient assume
assuming there's the dire need to meet
the the demand for addressing climate
change I know sure there are and whether
it's government assisting in the
training so that people can be hired
more quickly to do some of the jobs for
these energy retrofits to move to New
renewable Technologies or I'm sure
there's a dozen ways to do it but uh
bottom line I think the right way is the
government says we're investing in this
stuff we're going to get right to it and
then uh figure figure out the rest all
right Kevin thank you very much for the
call I do appreciate it
I like wine but I know very little about
it and I am completely clueless when I
go to a wine shop I just don't know what
I'm looking for I don't know what I'm
looking at I couldn't tell you anything
about varietals or if there's hints of
Persimmon or any of it and so if you're
like me wishing you had a seasoned
expert by your side when you're choosing
wine crunchy red fruit is the answer
crunchy red fruit delivers Choice
handcrafted small production wines right
to your door every bottle is hand-picked
by owner and master sommelier Jackson
rohrba in Seattle and comes with food
pairing suggestions we've been chatting
with Jackson his curating puts an
emphasis on organic low intervention
wines wines without artificial yeasts or
chemicals crunchy red fruit sources from
small scale sustainable Vineyards and
only wines that are true to their
location and grape crunchy red fruits
bi-monthly wine club is called the
circle every two months you'll get three
or six bottles to enjoy with videos to
help you appreciate what you're drinking
go to crunchyredfruit.com use the code
Pacman for twenty dollars off a single
purchase or if you join their bi-monthly
wine club send a message to circle
crunchyredfruit.com after you sign up
and they'll take twenty dollars off your
first shipment the link is down below